انا كان عمري اربع سنين وكنت كنا في
السعوديه
كنت عم اشوف ابي وجدي عم يلعبوا شطرنج
وبعدين تعلمتوا الشطرنج منهن واللعبه شكرا
اولا في المانيا
في بطولات اكثر وفي
مدربين اكثر وفي
كثير اشياء اكثر من غير يعني من سوريا
فهوني طبعا بقدر اطور مستوايا اكتر
وطبعا انا يعني هون عندي مدربين وعندي وعم
العب بطولات وهيك وعم بتدرب شوي
انا كنت فخور جدا لانه سمعت الخبر
ويعني
حاحاول اني اتدرب كثير وان شاء الله هحاول
افوز
يعني فريق الالماني اظن انه انه مليح وفي
لاعبين ممتازين وانه بنقدر نفوز في
البطوله
نعم يجب ان اعود بضع سنوات الى الوراء
مازلت اتذكر المره الاولى التي جاء فيها
حسين للتدريب كان لا يزال صغيرا جدا في
ذلك الوقت في الخامسه من عمره واصغر بكثير
من الناحيه البدنيه عما هو عليه اليوم
وجلس على السبوره وكان صغيرا جدا لدرجه
انه لم يستطع حتى الوصول الى الطرف الاخر
من اللوحه لكنني ادركت على الفور ان هناك
شيئا ما مميزا ينظر اكتشافه في هذا الطفل
الصغير
منهج كان لديه فهم سريع بشكل لا يصدق
للعبه ولم يكن يتحدث الالمانيه بشكل صحيح
في ذلك الوقت لكن ادائه في مباريات
الشطرنج كان مثيرا للاعجاب بشكل لا يصدق
حيث استوعب بسرعه محتوى التدريب
وكم كان متحمسا للشطرنج يمكنك ان تشعر به
عمليا منذ اليوم الاول حسين سيمثل منتخب
المانيا هذا شيء رائع للغايه لالمانيا
وايضا الحسين
[موسيقى]
دائما يعني نلعب بالعيله انا وابي او انا
واخواتي حسين بيجي بيتفرج بشوف شو عم
نلعبه يعني هل شغلات الاساسيه
القواعد الاساسيه تبعت اللعبه
وصار هو يعني يحاول يلعب يلعب ضد جده بس
بلشت احط له انا يعني مسائل مشان يحلها
كانت مهارات التكتيكيه يعني كتير عادي نحن
كنا متوقعين انه دعوه باي باي انا بالنسبه
لي اي لحظه بس
شوي مفاجاه يعني حسين أول ما اجينا سجلوا
بمدرسه وهني بيعملوا مثل
دعم للطلاب اللي بيجو الجداد فبيعملونا
الحصص اضافيه لتقويه باللغه الالمانيه
ونحن في البيت كمان نحاول
نساعدهم وبعدين دورت له انا على نادي
شطرنج عنا هون بالمدينه انا في رمضان بصوم
يعني طبعا بصوم الحمد لله وقبل الافطار او
يعني كم ساعه
بلعبلي شويه شطرنج او
يعني بلعب شطرنج او بالدرب شطرنج طموحي
اني اصير الروس ماستر وارفع بلد المانيا
وارفع بلد سوريا